il faut il faut vous dire que nous on
est victime du racisme à mort je sais et
je pense que on est une des communautés
les plus victimes du racisme en France
et aujourd'hui quand elle était je suis
devant ma télé je suis devant mes trucs
et je vois ce truc là mais ça me donne
envie de vomir tu comprends mon vin
l'assemblée je suis d'accord avec toi tu
sais pourquoi ça je me suis moi je me
suis amusé à remplacer
gitan par un autre mot puis il faut
habituel franchement en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que les expressions comme ça
c'est devenu du racisme ordinaire je
vais te donner un exemple ma petite elle
va à l'école ma petite elle va à l'école
c'est le carnaval tu sais ce qu'on lui
dit ma petite elle avait toujours porté
de pas avoir de déguisement je te jure
je te mens pas Siri c'est une vérité
donc elle dit à la maîtresse je peux
avoir comment je fais un déguisement tu
vois la femme elle lui dit écoute je
regarde ce qu'elle lui dit elle lui dit
découpe des rideaux des vieux rideaux on
va dans une friperie tu déguises en
gitane elle dit ça ma fille ma fille
elle rentre de l'école toute contente
mon père n'achète pas de costume elle me
dit j'essaie la maîtresse elle m'a donné
une bonne idée s'il vous plaît un peu de
respect pour ma communauté un peu de
respect pour toutes les communautés